hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play
hey sedale oh I am in la biblioteca and
we are trying to find the secrets to the
monster that's stalking us in trying to
murder us at every turn
okay other than that we're in relatively
the same place we started thankfully
it's Asahi da whatever the syeda means
and then there's this diabolical circle
parece que obey OMA ritual or a key okay
something about there's a ritual circle
here I don't know okay here's another
page I still don't know what all the
pages are for or why I'm collecting them
or why I need them or what they're gonna
be useful for in terms of defeating the
demon but so far all I know is that I
need to find keys and I have oh hello
this is the oh wait I've already gotten
this I'm just trying to get back to
where I was it dropped me just a little
bit before so hold on to your britches
we're getting this it's locked
poor oom trunk Kioto it's also locked
what key do I have I have one I had a
key
wait I had a key did I use it to get out
of the place I was no whatever let's
just get the page in here and then we
can carry on a merry way no HGS toilet
page lovely oh just my favorite a page
right out of the toilet okay that a page
water in the sink what I don't huh why
is there blood here is there some murder
from a diabolical monster
you think up would I do I'm so sorry
I'll put it back who are you what is
that for anyway Sallis ji lu up i Lola
what's that stuff for the fuse Han I can
get up can I get that fuse in there that
looks like it could be used for some
sort of fuse but see an interaction okay
with something happening here why did
that door closed was that say Kenny
Marie de uma porta de bon Jarrow one
euro same process a incorpo sim all
al-mulk and reblog haha what was that
how's a lady does a lady that was not
fair
I knew something was gonna happen why do
you have to do that yeah my heart can't
take these things calm down calm your
face okay there's another flare type
device not sure what that does maybe
that's the save mechanic solve our does
that mean save solve our progress oh
okay progress save okay all right I'm I
should have realized that a long time
ago but anyway I just got another one of
these for you sings let's go in here
nope still can't use it okay whatever
whatever whatever whatever whatever
whatever whatever core uh causes it ah
and a bloody handprint ooh shut up
quiet on my floor wherever we are some
sort of school diabolical demon school
ah God my god ah ah
gar you're real you're actually real
you're a real threat going get up here
put the hell with that
stupid stupid stupid go away you're
stupid
you weren't actually supposed to be real
you're supposed to be job hi oh you need
to stop I got it Wow
what what I don't know it's not fair you
get this booth booth booth you can't
just do that it's really unfair what nah
I bet stop it
oh man that's so stupid
that's so stupid shop you're in here
again aren't you hope what's it Oh wha
listen up dumb girl I'll trap you in the
super circle that's Chi that's right
lady get away get away I'm just gonna go
for the fuse and get out of there I do
not like you lady do not like ya
Oh run run run run run run run no no
girl down the hall who do not like that
girl I do not like that girl that girl
needs to go away from here let me save
again just in case in case I die for no
reason this game is stupid
this game is dumb I hate it hey where is
she huh I thought I heard something I
thought I saw some do it like a oh
there's a pentagram all thing on that is
there anything in here I need
doesn't look like any school I'd be
happy going to this is why our
educational system is in the toilet
why is my why is my flashlight
flickering I'm getting out of here hmm
you want to be here GUI of course
there's blood on the walls all the
tables just right now I'm like ah guy
not a god lady you need to get a chill
pill geez you just disappear real
quickly alright I got another fuse let
me try to well the blue one goes in the
blue fuse of course of course it does
that means there might be another fuse
in here I didn't see one at first but
never no nap I don't see one there's got
to be more fuses elsewhere but I just
don't know where what is that siren I'm
not doing anything
yeah that would take me alive coppers is
there anything actually in here did I go
in here okay did I I'm not sure I can't
remember I can't remember I'm losing my
memory is that girl gonna keep popping
up oh that looks a little complicated
for high school whatever uh not seeing
anything so I'm guessing hopefully these
rooms are just empty with the pentagram
all markings on the side nothing too
disturbing nothing to add a new you
ordinary just a little demonic influence
Wow go haha do big girl get away get
away get away get away oh my god
I'm done
there was nothing to be done okay
could not do anything they're so stupid
who the hell dude um where's she can't
disappear behind me that's unfair yeah I
know about the belt just let me get the
thing oh let's let me get the thing
there was something in that last room
that's where I gotta go
she doesn't keep popping up over the
place something here does gracile a
belieber this is the music room ah
oh it's toxic gas don't go in here
inside yes you're so stupid mark par
whose toxic gas oh that's why your
screen turned red blood filled your eyes
kind of gas it makes your eyes just
burst out of your head
kid you're so stupid mark huh is that
what everyone's saying I know you I know
you guys I know what you
I know what you would you really mean
but there was something in the
second-to-last room too besides the girl
wasn't there
nothing okay getting out of here mm
going upstairs cuz I could get caught on
corners it's not far
why is she stalking me it's because she
has a crush on me oh who doesn't have a
crush on the Oh some markiplier oh yeah
look so great
and handsome Susan okay
I don't know unleash my sexiness too
much on you on you of unsuspecting
audience members you know it's just I
cut you off guard and then you're just
like oh my god I need to file hello
gimme gimme gimme getting out getting up
the red fuse I don't know where the red
fuse goes how seriously I go into these
rooms and there's nothing so I don't
know what I'm supposed to expect here
maybe they're random and I got to go
back into the other rooms came like
there's another page some sort or
anything actually behind here nope
getting out of here never stayed too
long in one room that's what I've
learned that's what I'm talking to what
what's with the chair
that's her so wrong sitting there in the
middle
hello ah now yeah I got my okay Jimmy
can I thank you some soda
computron here a CD of sorts o CD I need
to put this downstairs in the thing you
gotta get me cuz just to check the last
one real quick another computer lab
another page
another anything or anything else go
quick quick quick quick quick quick like
bunnies right
gosh what did I go okay Karla lalalala
good I she's right behind you
Lucy's to learn go away
dojo judges shut up God what it would
that do start let me look at that some
sort of weirdo girl lady see those are
hollow photos no pentagram is vo a lot
Ayame Oh Dale a massive a la noche que
por debajo there can't a sir it's a
nunca for tostado okay so to get rid of
the girl I got to complete the pentagram
of sorts
that all know there is no how to do that
I wanna do that I don't know how to do
that
get rid of some tokuda did her to come
are a judo indicia k KR a cake oh come
on I was reading that okay let me just
save cuz I'm probably gonna have to go
back up and if I go back up I'm probably
going to die a horrible death
horrible sticky wet death alright so
anyway this pentagram I've got to
somehow lead her here but I need things
I need thingamabob errs and do Zima
what's its in order to get where I need
and I also need to get rid of the gas in
that room but I don't know how and I
also need to get this open because I'm
betting this has some places for more
fuses cuz I've got two more fuses and
supposedly there's two more somewhere in
there so I guess I just got to keep
looking here we go hmm there was a fuse
in here I know that I think it's pretty
scripted I don't think they're in random
places I just I just must have
overlooked some somewhere some somewhere
some somewhere some somewhere get down
get down
I don't know what that siren is but I
figured coincides with her and being up
I don't want her to hear me calling her
in bad name so so Hut's tugs between you
and me she's she's kind of mean she's a
meanie poopoo sticky head meanie Parvati
I hate the way you get caught unlike
things to your left and right was there
nothing in here I don't think there was
no that was not okay there was something
in this room and I don't know how to get
this gas off how do I get the gas ah God
I have nowhere to go
Oh your dog bed oh you know I all right
ah shop lady
Oh what you can't call me down here Oh
Oh what you can't come down here
Oh to pro for you I need to go all the
way to the top
actually I need to do none of the above
button here I go anyway I need to go
home and cry into a blanket but I'm a
press-on before you guys I need to
double check all these rooms because I
still know what the pages are for but
whatever there's got to be something in
these rooms that I'm missing because I
can't
there can't be nothing in here there's
got to be like some sort of a lever or
switch or controls to make the controls
that computer that was glowing wait a
minute
maybe there was some sort of
interactivity with it that I overlooked
in I know dammit
okay no all right I just stuck up here
do see good hey she's got I got a
there's an X on that chalkboard there I
could just look at it this flashlight
off lever yeah
fuse I do not I did I overlooked that
definitely okay cool cool cool kind of
cool there must be other guy yeah let's
tie run Oh get away get away get away
get away the people of this school like
set up a last-minute siren like D Li Li
Ling she's on her way
you're all boned maybe no no I can't see
my progress unless I am what Oh Bobby go
double you know in country for lost uh
French at UH para salvar Oprah everyone
talking about we're talking about
I saved too many times
they put a paper here to do one of these
oh yes sir oh well I didn't make too
much progress so I should be able to
catch up relatively quickly I can I save
I was a good date and let me check one
thing before I quit because I want to
make I want to see if putting that last
fuse in may the gas go away
nope gas still there huh I don't know
what to do about that so if you know
what to do about that write in the
comments below so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation
recorded music I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
ah
bud
Oh
Oh